Hi, hier ist wieder das Podcast-Ufo.
Das Podcast-Ufo? Das Podcast-Ufo meinst du? Das ist doch der Comedy-Podcast, der mir jede Woche mein Leben versüsst, oder? Genau. Als Hörer in des Das Podcast-Ufo-Podcasts, DPU, hast du Zugang zum witzigsten und unterhaltsamsten Content der Podcast-Welt. Höre jetzt rein in die allerneuste Folge. Gute Unterhaltung wünschen dir Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will. Viel Spaß! Hey, hallo, herzlich willkommen zur Folge. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Wie ihr es gerade gehört habt, es sind Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will. Das können wir aber auch selber sagen, wir wissen ja selber, wie wir heissen. Vielen, vielen Dank an Ildiko, die uns dieses fantastische Intro gesprochen hat, mal eine andere Richtung, Spoken Word. Mal eine andere Richtung, aber auch nicht gereimtes Spoken Word. Also das war wirklich
die Mindestanforderungen,
eine MP3-File,
was uns geschickt wurde, wurden erfüllt,
und dann habt ihr auch eine Chance, hier gespielt zu werden.
Vielen Dank fürs Intro.
Richtiger Codec, richtig verschlüsselt, also ich fand's
klasse. Vielen, vielen Dank an der Stelle,
und mal gucken, in welche Sphären des Intros
uns das noch bringen kann, also
ob irgendwann wirklich mal
ein Tier oder so eine Atmosphäre oder mal was Ambient-mäßiges kommt oder sowas in der Richtung. Oder sowas Stomp-mäßiges, wo dann Leute so auf Töpfen trommeln oder sowas in der Richtung. Oder halt nichts mehr und wir fangen einfach an zu reden, wie das mal hundert Folgen zwischendurch, die berühmten hundert Loch Folgen der Fall war. Der längste Copyright-Prozess aller Zeiten, wo wir uns hundert Folgen lang überlegt haben, ob wir weiterhin ein Intro von Disney verwenden sollen oder lieber nicht. Wo wir hundert Folgen darüber nachgedacht über den Satz Was er nicht weiss, macht ihn nicht heiss. Und gleichzeitig auch parallel dazu über den Satz Wo kein Kläger, da kein Richter. Ja, wo kein Richter, da kein Henker, wo kein Henker, da kein Problem. So, da kann man das Jurastudium abkürzen. Wir hatten diese drei Sentenzen und das BGB und mit den beiden Quellen haben wir versucht, das Wort Sentenz, ach so, zum zweiten Mal benutzt. Ja. Und ich glaube, bei Duden, wenn ich bei Duden.de gucke, hat das eine Häufigkeit von eins. Da denke ich sofort drüber nach, wo hast du das aufgeschnappt und warum benutzt du das heute so häufig? Ich versuche jeden Tag, ein Wort zu benutzen. Und heute ist Sentence. Heute ist Sentence. Ich schlage immer meinen Duden auf, gucke mir ein Wort an, und das versuche ich den Tag zu retten. Und du bist schon bei S oder du schlägst es random auf? Nee, nee, ich schlag random auf. Okay, nein, ich versuche jeden Tag, meinen Wortschatz zu ... also ... Größer zu machenchatz zu also größer zu machen. Das ist mir ganz wichtig, damit wir auch vorankommen. Der Podcast soll ja hier nicht rumhängen oder so, sondern wir sollen mal vorankommen auch. Man müsste in 300 Folgen mal was schaffen, wenn die Leute immer sagen, wir haben ein paar Sachen geschafft. 300 Folgen, was habt ihr denn erreicht? Wir haben ein paar Sachen geschafft. Wir haben viele Sachen noch nicht geschafft. Aber wir kommen nicht so richtig voran. Es ist immer so viele Einser gewürfelt. Es ist immer so, jetzt komm, der nächste Schritt. Wir haben zu viele Metaphern auf, zu viele Einser gewürfelt und zu viele Klammern auf. Wir haben zu viele Klammern auf, ja. Wir haben 16 Klammern offen, ob wir die heute zukriegen. Aber ich habe gerade darüber nachgedacht, weil ich habe mal einmal irgendwem beim Umzug geholfen und plötzlich kam ein Richter. Also da war auch einfach ein Familienmitglied war ein Richter. Ach so, in Robe? Nicht in Robe, aber in so einer Richterhaftigkeit. Also alles an ihm, Körperhaltung, dieser Humor, alles hat gesagt, ich bin Richter. Und dann habe ich über das Sprichwort nachgedacht, wo kein Kläger, da kein Richter und dachte mir, was ist ein Unsinn, jetzt habe ich hier das Problem vor mir stehen. Oder in dem Fall, wo kein Träger, da kein Richter. Ja, nee, wo kein Träger, da ein Richter, der sagt, wo ist denn hier der Träger? Oder, um es mal kritisch zu sagen, wo ein Richter, da kein Träger, da können wir nämlich auch sagen, weil so angepackt hat er nämlich nicht. Die Pizza war sofort weg, aber das Sofa nicht. Schön, klar, das Jevers, da macht man sich drei Flaschen auf, aber da mal schön die Teller schleppen, nee, das geht da nicht. Im Namen des Volkes, abgelehnt. Abgelehnt. Jedenfalls, da habe ich ein bisschen Schiss gehabt. Ich habe wirklich so eine Obrigkeitsangst, muss ich echt sagen. So eine Autoritätsgläubigkeit, Obrigkeitsgläubigkeit. Vor allem, also wir sind natürlich alle sozialisiert, vor allem mit amerikanischen Dramas, courtroom-Dramas, wo man das
geschworenen Gericht hat. Und das versteht jeder
Mensch. Da sind zwölf Leute, wenn man
die überzeugen kann, kommt man frei, wenn nicht, geht man
ins Gefängnis. Easy.
Dem entgegengesetzt habe ich das deutsche
System nicht verstanden. Da gibt es
eigentlich nur einen Typen, den Richter, und wenn
du den überzeugen kannst, hast du gewonnen.
Nee, das sind noch zwei Chefen, die können den auch überstehen.
Zwei Chefen auch noch. Also es sind einfach nur weniger Geschworene, oder was? Und die sind besser ausgebildet? Nee, die Chefen sind auch nicht ausgebildet. Der Richter hat mehr ... In Deutschland, wie ich es mir gemerkt habe, ist, die Leute, die Ahnung haben vom juristischen System, treffen die Entscheidung. In Amerika nicht. Okay. Gerade die, die gerade keine Ahnung haben. Und in Amerika denke ich auf jedem Urteil so, ja, Unsinn. Das sind so wie ich beim True Crime gucken, haben die jetzt halt sich so entschieden. Nach der ersten Staffel sich so entschieden und dann kommt die zweite und dann nennt sich auch. Aber wenn jetzt die zweite kommt und dann ging die Berufung und so. Es war die Eule die ganze Zeit. Ja genau, dann war es dann doch die Eule. Übrigens hier an der Stelle schon mal ein sehr früher Tipp, machen wir normalerweise am Ende der Folge. The Staircase, habe ich damals viel von gesprochen, gibt es diese berühmte Dokumentation darüber auf Netflix, von französischen Filmemachern, davor schon gemacht worden, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die bei Netflix nochmal angefasst wurde oder so, wie dem auch sei, gibt es jetzt eine ganz, ganz tolle Fiction-Serie darüber, die ist ganz, ganz, ganz fantastisch auf HBO zu schauen, heisst auch The Staircase, mit dem wunderbaren Colin Firth, mit Toni Collette, also wie ein ganz toller Cast, Michael Stuhlbarg, irre cool. Und, ich will nicht zu viel verraten, aber die Eule kommt auch da drin vor. Ja? Spielt Colin Firth die Eule? Colin Firth spricht eine Eule. Firth sings Firth, spielt er die Eule? Mir fängt normal an, wenn es irgendwann wie Space Jam,
hast du dann plötzlich so eine animierte Eule da drin.
Offensichtlich eine Zeichentrick-Eule, ja.
Ja, eine Zeichentrick-Eule da drin.
Finde ich auch viel besser, ehrlich gesagt, als dieses fotorealistische CGI,
einfach mal offensichtlich zeigen, nee, das ist eine Comicfigur.
Ja.
Einfach eine gemalte Comicfigur, wie so ein Strichmännchen,
dass es einfach klar ist, dass du gar nicht in dieses Uncanny Valley reinkommst.
Ich bin da seit Jahren drin, ich komme nicht mehr raus. Du machst seit Jahren Urlaub im Uncanny Valley. Ich finde, es klingt wirklich wie ein toller Urlaub. Gab es doch bestimmt schon irgendeine SpongeBob-Folge, Urlaub im Uncanny Valley oder irgendwie eine Rick and Morty. Das würde eher zu Rick and Morty passen, wo alle so halb realistisch sind oder sowas. Ich finde, SpongeBob wird sehr, sehr krass romantisiert und verklärt. Oh, hot take! Ich zieh mich zurück. Dieses ganze, alle Figuren stellen die sieben Todsünden dar. So wird Spongebob rezipiert heute in der modernen Gasteswissenschaft? Ja, mit so einem Monokel, mit so einer tiefsitzenden Brille. Ach, das wuss ich gar nicht. Und mit langen, weißen, gelockten Haaren wird so Spongebob rezipiert. Das finde ich interessant, dass das auch in den wirklich literaturwissenschaftlichen Kanon aufgenommen wird. Wenn man so Shakespeare oder sowas heute total ernst genommen wird, war damals vielleicht totaler Trash. So einfach so kompletter Trash, so historische Figuren, Kleopatra und Caesar, mein Gott, die alte Nudel wieder. Das Lagerfeuerlied, also es war auch nicht so in Macbeth gefasst. Ich habe das so kommen sehen, dass Romeo und Julia sich umbringen. Ich habe wirklich im ersten Akt, im ersten Akt, das war so vorhersehbar. Ich habe das schon vorhergesehen und heute U interpretiert oder sowas. Finde ich gut, dass Spunschweitz auch diesen Schritt gemacht hat. Vor allem immer, man ist ja sehr, sehr kritisch mit der Gegenwart. Man ist sehr glimpflich mit der Vergangenheit. Weil wir sie noch ändern können!
Ja, es ist aber interessant, weil jetzt gerade ...
Sorry, ich war nicht gerechtfertigt.
Ich dachte ...
Nee, du bist zu viel ...
Ich dachte, es geht in so eine emotionale Richtung.
Du bist noch weniger auf dem Tisch.
Sorry, okay, Entschuldigung.
Aber diese Marvel-Filme, ne, gerade das Kino geht vor die Hunde,
es gibt keine guten Filme mehr, stimmt sicher auch so.
Aber man redet immer nur so über die Gegenwart.
Vor zehn Jahren habe ich auch schon über die Gegenwart gesprochen. Mittlerweile denke ich, mich hätte gerne die Filme von vor zehn Jahren zogen. Du hörst selten Rant, wo du sagst, Alter, 2003? Da kamen ja nur Scheißfilme raus, oder? Also da war das Kinojahr ja wirklich komplett verhunzt. Also was da für Quatsch kam und alle so, ja, das war schon ewig vorbei. 2003. Ja, was war da, King's Speech? Nee, 2009. 2003 Oscars, also Herr der Ringe, zwei Türme. Ja, okay, gut, das war schon ewig vorbei. 2003. Was war da King's Speech? Nee, 2009.
2003 Oscars, also Herr der Ringe, zwei Türme.
Ja, okay, gut, das war natürlich ein gewisses, ein cineastischer Stillstand, könnte man natürlich sagen, weil natürlich alle drei Filme erstmal abgeklappert werden müssen bei den Oscars und so.
Da ist natürlich viel Gutes unter den Teppich gefallen, das kann man natürlich schon sagen.
Adrian Brody hat gewonnen für seine Rolle in The Pianist, Roman Polanski hat gewonnen, okay, wie viel Jahrgang. Nicole Kidman hat gewonnen, guck mal, das war doch was los, Catherine Zeta-Jones für Chicago. Ich meine, das war doch wirklich ein guter Jahrgang. Niemand kann was gegen 2003 sagen. Nee, das war richtig gut. Gangs of New York, Chicago, The Hours, Herr der Finger. Also, gut. Aber verstehst du, was ich meine? Man redet sehr, sehr fies, kritisch mit der Gegenwart. Man ist da sehr genau, schon genau hin. Ja, das stimmt. Wohingegen Spongebob jetzt nachhaltig als intellektuelles Meisterwerk. Weil es übrig geblieben ist im kollektiven Gedächtnis. Da ist irgendwie das Masupilami fällt langsam raus, muss man sagen. Das Masupilami fällt langsam aber sicher aus dem kollektiven Gedächtnis raus. Ich habe lange nicht mehr an Kaju gedacht, muss man sagen. Der kleine Trottel. Warum hat ein Kind eine Glatze? Was ist da los? Weiss man es? Oh, ist es eine Chemotherapie? Ich glaube, es ist nicht. Es ist eine modische Entscheidung, sich auch die Augenbrauen abzurasieren. Ich glaube nicht. Das ist noch lieber etwas Fortschrumpf. Zum Thema dumme Vergangenheit. Sehr gut. Es kam noch mehr zum Thema, Herr der Ringe ist eigentlich doch komplett bescheuert. Ah ja? Und zwar haben wir esgedröselt, dass viele der Herr der Ringe Namen gar nicht den ursprünglichen Namen haben. Also Frodo Beutlin heißt gar nicht Frodo Beutlin, das ist nur die englische Übersetzung des Originalnamens. Der Originalnamen ist Mauerla Binky. Und jetzt haben die Herr der Ringe Wissenschaftler festgestellt, nee, die englischen Namen sind auch bescheuert, also sind alle bescheuert.
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht, wie die englischen Namen sind. Und zwar die Familie von Bilbo Beutlin. Heißt, also wer ist jetzt Mungo Beutlin? Mungo Beutlin, ältester Sohn von Balbo Beutlin. Jetzt geht es einfach nur einwand. Also Mungo Beutlin, ältester Sohn von Balbo Beutlin, war ein Hobbit, da steht noch Hobbit, des Auenlandes, der in den Jahren 2807, DZ, 12, ja okay, ganz viele Jahreszahlen des dritten Zeitrautes lebte. Über sein Leben ist nur bekannt, dass er Laura Beutlin, geboren Gruber, erratete, geboren Gruber. Warte, aber es geht noch hier und weiter. Er hat und mit ihr fünf Kinder hatte, zu seiner Zeit Oberhaupt der Beutlins war. Die Kinder. Die Kinder von Mungo Beutlin und Laura Gruber lauten Bungo Beutlin, Bailba Beutlin, Longo Beutlin, Linda Beutlin und Bingo Beutlin. Bingo Beutlin, schade, dass der nicht die Hauptfigur von der Herr der Ringe geworden ist, sondern Frodo. Schade, dass Bingo Beutlin so selten vorkommt. Aber Linda, Linda Beutlin. Linda ist auch gut, Laura Beutlin, das ist die Frauen einfach normale. Laura Gruber. Susanne Beutlin. Sie einfach, die Frauen, deshalb hat der Tolkien eigentlich gesagt, komm, die Frauen nennen wir alle so, wie die Leute, die ich kennen. Aber was ist jetzt da der neueste Twist? Also warum haben die jetzt nochmal andere Namen? Das sind einfach die englischen Namen. Nee, ich dachte nur, weil viele bei Herr der Ringe, Gimli, Legolas, Aragon, Arator, Aven, so, nee, aber es gibt halt auch Bingo. Es gibt auch Bingo und Laura und... Es gibt einfach Bingo und Belba und Mungo. Also es gibt einfach auch ... Wobei, gestrengenommen, Mungo, Bulbo und Bingo passen, finde ich, gar nicht so schlecht in Legolas, Arwen und so rein. Wirklich, Bingo. Ich hänge mich eher an Laura Gruber auf, hätte ich gesagt. Du hättest im Kino nicht bei Bingo kurz innegehalten und gesagt, sorry, noch mal, doch, noch mal, als die Gefährten aufgezählt wurden, Gandalf, Borumi und Bingo, noch mal, Entschuldigung, haben wir Untertitel, können wir die, Entschuldigung, können wir die Untertitel anmachen? Klar, schmeiß ich euch rein, und dann nimmt er so eine Kelle, macht so Kohle drauf und macht dir die Untertitel in den Ofen, so drei Schaufeln Buchstaben rein, und dann so Flammen. So Projektionsraum, so Rauchschwan. Und unter die Maschine wurde angeschmissen. Nee, bei Bingo hätte ich auch aufgehorcht. Bei Laura Gruber hätte ich angesagt, so, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp wo er gesagt hat, ja für Kinder, wie heißt es, Bingo, Bolbo, Bibo und dann halt der Herr der Ringe, wo es ernster wurde, aber dann hat man halt diesen ganzen dummen Namen und dann so, ja, dann ist es halt irgendwie Verwandtschaft, die kommen halt da nicht vor, so. Ich glaube auch, dass Frodo als Figur umstritten, natürlich auch in der Geschichte des Geschichtenerzählens, aber ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass wenn Tolkien konfrontiert worden wäre mit der ist langweilig, der hat keine eigene Motivation, der macht das nur, weil er da reinrutscht in die Situation, hätte er gesagt ja, aber er hat keinen peinlichen Namen. Das war primär der Grund, warum genau er der Held der Geschichte ist, weil, ne, also Bingo ist ein ganz tiefgründiger, interessanter Charakter, Kindheitstraumata und so, der wollte sich beweisen. Wollte einen, bei dem es mehr Sinn ergeben würde, der auf Abenteuer steht, aber Blob Blob heißt, dann loszieht und lernt, ah, vielleicht wäre er lieber im Augenland geblieben, als diesen langweiligen, passiven, immerhin Frodo. Frodo ist immerhin ein guter Name, ja. Das kann man sich immerhin merken. Aber das stimmt schon, ne? Also in der Geschichte des Geschichtenerzählens, wie du gerade so schön formuliert hast, ist die Geschichte von Frodo Beutlin ein bisschen umstritten. Oder nicht? Weil es ist schon eine merkwürdige Idee, den einen von, man lernt ja viele Haudegen kennen bei den Hobbits. Bei den Mittelländern. Bei den Hobbits. Bei den Hobbits. Mittel-Erdlingen. Nee, bei den Hobbits, weil die wollen ja schon auch raus. Und manche davon wollen Abenteuer bestehen. Meinend Pippin und wie heißt der andere? Malon. So, Martin. Martin Gruber. Und Sam ist ja in gewisser Weise auch, klar, gemütlich und so, ja, weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich auch eher nicht. Aber es ist nicht doof, quasi den einen, der gar nichts will und auch gar nichts, weil er lernt am Ende gefährlich, die Last der Welt auf seinen Schultern, klar, kommt zurück und ist eigentlich immer noch der Ansicht, dass er nicht für Abenteuer gebraucht zu haben ist. Ich glaube, das Ding ist ja, dass die Geschichte darum geht, jeder kann ein Held sein, selbst der, der nur gemütlich zu Hause sitzen will, so wie der Leser, sondern jeder kann ein Abenteurer sein. Aber die Geschichte ist auch so inkonsequent, weil sie ja eigentlich immer nur Foto so eine Karotte vor die Nase hält, so ah, ihr müsst nach Bre, okay, wir gehen nach Bre. Nee, ihr müsst jetzt doch nach Bruchtal.
Okay, dann gehen wir jetzt ein Stück weiter nach Bruchtal. Innerere Motivation.
Was auch niemandem als gesagt hat. Nope. Okay, gehen wir nach Bruchtal.
Okay. Gehen wir zu den Wasserfällen
und zu den Elben nach Bruchtal.
Ja, und dann werden sie in Bruchtal sein. Blame.
Bruchtal. Jetzt, wo ihr hier seid.
Moment mal, ich habe erst hundert Seiten durch.
Das war's schon. Nee, nee, nee. Jetzt müsst ihr noch
nach Mordor. Okay. Gut, jetzt sind wir schon in Bruchzahl. Jetzt sind wir schon hier. Jetzt gehen wir da hin. So los geht's. Aber keine innere Motivation. Nee, keine innere Motivation. Hauptsache sympathisch. Aaron Tolkien sagt Intention und Obstacle. Und Tolkien sagt Obstacle and Obstacle and Obstacle and a Mountain. there's a Mountain, there's a fire demon and there's so many obstacles and there's so many stupid, may I add, there are also so many stupid names I can come up with. Wohingegen Aaron Solkin sagt, Namen sind das Schwierigste, um sich das auszudenken, und er geht an so alte College-Football-Teams. Ja, und seine Hauptfigur heißt dann Mark Zuckerberg oder was. Wow. Ja, genau, ich habe auch gedacht. Da hat er sich richtig angestrengt. Was ein dusseliger Name, habe ich gedacht. Aaron Sorkin hat den Film The Social Network geschrieben. Regie führte David Fincher. Fincher. Er hat aber auch tolle Serien wie The Newsroom oder West Wing geschrieben. West Wing. West Wing. Tolle Serien. Kannst du dich noch an diese herrliche House of Cards-Zeit erinnern, als wir alle so gesprochen haben? Als wir immer nur West Wing, what, what do you want of me? Wenn ich Englisch Muttersprachler gewesen wäre, zu einer Zeit von House of Cards, unausstehlich. Ich würde ihn auch so sprechen. Will man ja nicht. Hier ist der Parlament Hwep. Immer noch übrigens fantastisch, dass es eine Family Guy-Gag funktioniert, wo Stewie immer Cool Hwep sagt. Ja, ja, ja, Schlagsahne. Und sagt, say cool, say cool, say cool, say whip, whip, say cool, whip, cool, hwep. Und mit dem gleichen deutschen Wort Schlagsahne, Schlagsahne funktioniert es auch. Das ist ja unglaublich, das ist ja unglaublich. Gute deutsche Übersetzungen sind das Schönste, was es gibt, wenn es so genau reinfällt, wenn es so perfekt ist. Aber es fällt ja dem Übersetzter, der Übersetzterin in den Schoss. Ja, ja. Da ist ja keine Eigenleistung, musste vollbracht werden. Ja, ich habe letztens nochmal, habe ich extra nochmal die Serie aufgerufen, Arrested Development, wo es ja eine Figur gibt, die heisst Lucille. Und dann gibt es eine Szene in der Serie, als jemand ins Meer geht und jemand anders möchte ihn warnen, dass ein Seehund ausser Kontrolle ist und ruft Lucille, Lucille. Und er sagt Lucille, seine Mutter heißt Lucille. So, legendäre Szene, und da kam ich nicht umhin, dann doch noch mal in die Köpfe der Übersetzer hineinzuschauen, die sich dachten, Seehund, Rob, vor allem, der Name Lucille war ja vor dem Auftrafen des Gags bekannt. Ist ja nicht so, dass dann da steht, wenn man dann das Drehbuch bekommt, Lucille Sternchen in Staffel vier, Folge acht, muss es irgendwie als Wortspiel passen. Ja genau, nennst du jetzt schon Robby Robb. Nennst du jetzt schon wütende Robbe, sonst macht das hinten gar keinen Sinn mehr. Und das ist ja auch spannend, dass man ja quasi mit den Drehbüchern gehen muss. Und jetzt heißt sie schon mal Lucille im Deutschen. Und dann?
Und dann habe ich wirklich nochmal die komplette Staffel nochmal auf Deutsch geguckt bis zu diesem Punkt, um einfach wirklich nur diese Momente Irritation und Verzweiflung mitzuerleben, als die Figur dann schreit, Gefahr, Gefahr. Also man hat aufgegeben vor dieser Aufgabe. Zu Recht würde ich sagen, ich möchte niemandem was ankreiden, wer auch immer da die Feder geschwungen hat. Es ist unübersetzbar, leider. Gefahr, Gefahr? Ja, was soll man denn machen? Der muss ja irgendwas rufen. Der kann ja nicht die Lippen bewegen oder einfach mehr.
Naja, wer hätte ja rufen können. Na gut, Gefahr, Gefahr ist schon ein bisschen irritierend, ne? Also schon ist es auch irgendwie lustig, weil natürlich niemand stellt sich an den Strandhundruf Gefahr, Gefahr, sondern man würde ja eher sagen, was es ist. Ich glaube auch, dass ich irgendeinen Gag übersehen habe.
Vielleicht ist er irgendein Gag, eigentlich habe ich ihn nicht gesehen.
Ja, das ist schwierig, aber interessant.
Das sollten wir immer noch machen,gende Folge mit einem Übersetzer. Oh ja, das finde ich richtig gut. Und dann überlegen wir uns richtig schwere Sätze auf Englisch, mit richtig schweren Wortspielen, und gucken, ob die Person das dann übersetzen kann oder nicht. On the fly, ja. On the fly, oder fliegende Übersetzung, fliegender Staat, geht, geht, geht, geht. Oder ihr schickt uns eure Lieblingsgags auf dem Englischen, eure lieblings unübersetzbaren Gags. Wir hatten ja auch schon ein paar hier, Jack Sparrow, I'd rather be stoned, Lucille und genau, deswegen wäre es spannend, schickt uns eure Lieblingsgags aus dem Englischen, die im Deutschen nicht funktionieren und wir sagen hier dann on the fly dem Übersetzer der Übersetzerin diese Gags und der muss sie übersetzen. Vielleicht kriegen wir Frank Schacht, Frank Schacht, der Übersetzer von der Ocean's Eleven, der immer noch das Geheimnis in sich trägt, was zur Hölle mit Gummibärchen in der Minibar gemeint war. Wenn wir ihn da vielleicht aufkratzen, wenn wir ihn aufhacken, dann kriegen wir das vielleicht raus aus seinem Kopf. Das ist ja da drin, das Wissen, das ist ja so frustrierend. Ich habe mal gelernt, wenn man Leuten was zu essen zu trinken gibt, dann erzählen sie mehr. Das ist ja der alte Trick. Was? Egal was? Ja, generell, die öffnen sich mehr und erzählen dann mehr. Das ist auch was saures vielleicht, oder? Es gibt auch diese Talkshow mit den ganz scharfen Wings, wo die Leute dann so wahnsinnig werden irgendwann, dass sie alles erzählen und ihre Adresse nennen und alles und ihre Kontonummer und Pinnnummer und so.
Hot Ones.
Weil sie einfach so am Ende sind wegen dieser Schärfe.
Das ist auch gemein, das ist Folter.
Hot Ones heißt das, aber mein Gehirn hat das immer falsch gelesen, weil das Logo ist gelb-rot, bisschen wie die spanische Flagge.
Deswegen habe ich immer Hot Ones gelesen. Hot Ones und ich irgendwann so, ach, Hot Ones. Kann jeder, diese kurzen, Hot Ones, aber diese kurzen Momente des Enttäuschtseins über sich, hat man ja manchmal, wo man dann so vor dem Laptop sitzt und sich so ein Brötchen reinschiebt und dann nebenbei Hot Ones guckt und denkt, ach, Hot Ones. Ist doch nicht cool. Aber man will es auch nicht laut. Schaltet es ab. Ja, aber hier ist dieser Hass auf sich selbst. Ach, schau. Ja, ja, ja. Zum Glück hast du es auch nicht Leuten empfohlen. Ja, genau. Du musst diese Sendung sehen, Hot Ones. Das ist so gut. Du meinst Hot Ones? Wie damals, als ich allen Leuten Tup empfohlen habe und dann korrigiert wurde, nein, es heisst Seven Up. Das wiss ich nicht. Tup. Aber war ein heisser Tipp für dich. Leute, wenn ihr Sprite mögt und diesen herrlichen Zitronen geschmeckt, diese erfrischende Süße, dieses prickelnde Gefühl auf dem Mund, probiert mal Tup. Schmeckt ähnlich. Es ist nicht besser. Es ist exakt das gleiche. Ich meine, es sind Zitronen. Was soll man da machen? Es sind einfach Zitronen. Es ist Zitrone, Zucker, Wasser. Und Kohlensäure. Viel mehr passiert da nicht. Nee, du hast es mir empfohlen. Ich weiß nicht, warum du so zurückruderst. Und weißt du, was auch geil damit ist? Diese Cracker. Oh, wir haben das glaube ich schon mal erzählt.
Weil der Gag Seven Oak das...
Der Tuck. Ja genau. Ich glaube, wir haben
das schon mal exakt so erzählt. In Folge vier
oder so. Ja, das kann gut sein. Aber die hören ja nicht alle Leute.
Nee, nee, nee. Ich denke mir jetzt auch,
manchmal machen wir alte Folgen, weil das wird ja auch gemacht,
neue Bands legen ja alte
Alben auf, noch neu. Ah, okay. So remastered.
Und ich würde behaupten,
wir sind ja jetzt besser vom Mikro als vor
fünf Jahren, weiß ich nicht.
Vielleicht sollen wir jetzt noch mal alte Folgen
abschreiben und noch mal neu einsprechen.
Genau, ja. Ja, wirklich.
Ja, okay.
Weil wir haben jetzt noch bessere Soundqualität.
Und es gibt mittlerweile auch gute Software, die das dann einfach
transkribieren kann, dann können wir das alles direkt
wieder einspielen. Du hattest mal deine nasale Phase, wo du ein bisschen nasal gesprochen hast. Ja. Ja, ja, das ist wichtig. Das können wir wiederholen. Das war nicht nasal, ich war übergewichtig. Ich hatte viel Fett, vor allem in der Nase. Das ist so meine Hauptproblemzone. Da gehe ich ins Gym und sage dann, ja, ich würde gerne nur an der Nase abnehmen. Woran wollen Sie arbeiten? Wollen Sie ein bisschen athletischer werden, wollen Sie ein bisschen abnehmen? Und dann haben die diese ganz kleinen Handeln, die legen sie mir auf die Nase, wie so eine ganz kleine Brille, aber es ist so ein Gewicht und dann muss ich nur mit der Nase hoch und runter die ganze Zeit. Kannst du mit den Nasenflügeln so machen? Nee, offensichtlich nicht wirklich, weil ich kann die so auseinander machen. Aber ist da ein Muskel dahinter, also könntest du das jetzt trainieren, wenn man dir so eine Klammer um die Nase gibt, dass du die so aufdrückst? Ja genau. Oder ich könnte mich auf die Seite legen, da legst du dein kleines Gewicht drauf und dann muss ich das immer hoch machen. Das geht schon. Ja viele Leute, also viele Leute sagen ja über dich, du hättest wenig Ausdruck im Gesicht, also du wärst recht schlapp im Gesicht, also wenig Spannung und man kann Emotionen nicht so gut ablesen bei dir. Okay. Das heisst, vielleicht wird, deine Gesichtsmuskulatur zu stärken. Es gab für Nintendo DS, glaube ich, auch mal so ein Spiel, wo man Gesichtsmuskulatur, weil die hatten ja so diesen Riesenerfolg mit Doktor Kawasaki. Das war Doktor Kawashimas Brain Training. Genau, und dann dachten die sich, fuck, was kann man noch trainieren, wie wäre es mit dem Gesicht? Und dann war es wirklich so ein Spiel, wo du machen musstest, du musstest lächeln und Stirn runzeln, Augen auf und Augen zu, einfach um dein Gesicht zu trainieren. Und am Ende hattest du so ein richtig muskulöses Gesicht, wo du so einen richtigen Wangenbizeps einfach hast, den du so immer anspannen kannst. Aber ist das wirklich so? Sind das auch Muskeln, die man trainieren kann und größer machen kann? Du kannst jeden Muskel trainieren, wie du willst. Warum sagst du das mit diesem Lächeln, mit diesem Lächeln so als ob du mir gleich so eine blaue und eine rote Pille gibst. Du kannst jeden Muskel trainieren, jeden, egal an welcher Körperstelle, jeder Muskel. Okay, Entschuldige mich. Okay. Wir verstehen uns? Ja, ich bin kurz raus für ein Stöhnchen, dann komme ich wieder. Ich habe die stärkste Niere der Welt. Schön Gewichte drauf, alles Muskeln. Kannst du alles trainieren, kannst du alles lernen. Nieren habe ich auch nicht verstanden. Mal zwei. Das ist eher so. Warum nicht zwei Herzen, also meines als Idee, weil es auch wichtig ist. Alles, was in der Mitte liegt, gibt es, alles, was symmetrisch ist, nee. Alles, was in der Mitte liegt, gibt es einmal, den Rest gibt es zweimal. Außer das Herz, das ist einfach nur links. Aber alles, was auf der Mitte liegt, existiert einmal, ein Gehirn, eine Nase, ein Mund, ein Kinn, aber alles, was neben der Mittelachse liegt, gibt es zweimal. So wirklich wie einmal durchgeschnitten und gespielt. Damit man den Menschen einmal so in der Mitte zusammenklappen könnte, wenn es nötig nicht wäre, könnte man den einmal zusammenklappen. Ja, damit man mit diesem Rorschach-Test, damit es einfacher ist, den zu zeigen. Das ist alles symmetrisch. Es ist einfach Copy-Paste. Man hat einfach die Hälfte gemacht, dann haben die keine Zeit mehr gehabt, dann haben wir überlegt, ja komm, dann machen wir eher drei Hälfte nochmal. Außer beim Herz quasi, das ist halt links, das ist ein bisschen merkwürdig, das müsste ja eigentlich in der Mitte sein. Aber wandert es nicht langsam in die Mitte? Du, ich weiß es nicht, es kommt darauf an, wenn du dich ganz schnell um die eigene Achse drehst, dann wandert das Herz ja weiter nach außen. Zentripetalkräfte, wissen wir. Wissen wir alles. Das heißt, je weniger man sich dreht, desto mehr kann das Herz sich nach innen arbeiten.
Hast du die These aufgestellt, dass wir uns alle zu doll im Kreis gedreht haben und deswegen das Herz nach links außen gerutscht ist? Es gab in der Geschichte des Menschen mal eine 20.000-Jahr-Phase, wo die Menschen sich wahnsinnig schnell gedreht haben. Nervig. Weil die Erde ganz klein. Und deswegen haben sich alle so schnell gedreht. Nee, pass auf, die Menschen haben mehr an den Polen gelebt, und deswegen haben sie sich durch die Erde mehr um sich selber gedreht, als wenn du aussen stehst und eher beim Karussell aussen bist. Und das Herbst ist nach links gerutscht. Das nach aussen. Okay. Also, ja, warum nicht? Ich finde es auch ... Kannst du alles erklären, Stefan. Wenn du Fragen hast, gerne. Wenn du Fragen hast, wende dich gerne an mich. Kannst du mir gerne, auch privat oder so per Nachricht oder so, schick mir gerne, falls irgendwas offen ist, schick mir gerne eine Frage. Soll ich dir mehr Sachen schicken privat? Frag mich gerne Sachen. Ich habe oft Zeit. Also so ist es nicht. So ist es nicht. Wir haben letztes Mal besprochen über Enten und Enten
an blöden Orten und wir haben vielen Dank,
weil es ist wirklich so, als
wir mittlerweile die Community aus einer Stimme
sprechen, weil wir kriegen dann, ich weiß nicht,
wie oft ich dieses Video geschickt bekommen habe. Ja, es war demokratisch eindeutig,
das kann man sagen. Ein Video, wo
eine Ente in einem
Freizeitpark
gelebt hat und da
genau, und im Freizeitpark ist glaube ich der blödeste Ort für Ent Enten egal. Es ist kein Ort für Enten. Nein. Nicht für Enten gemacht. Aber natürlich lädt es Enten ein, weil viele Wasserflächen, viele Pommes auf dem Boden, viel zu essen, viel los, viel zu gucken, viel Menschen beobachten, schön. So, und Problem ist aber, dass die halt dann da sich hinsetzen auf, jaartige Fontänenenten und denken dann, dass sie da gut erstmal ein Stündchen sitzen können, ohne zu wissen, dass im Freitagspark natürlich alles ein bisschen auf den Effekt, auf die Überraschung ausgelegt ist und grosse Fontänen aus dem Boden springen, Springbrunnen und Enten in die Luft geworfen werden, um dann wieder woanders zu landen. Es ist ein grandioses Video. Es ist ein Video, du siehst eine Ente, die ist tiefenentspannt, wirklich so. Manchmal, ich weiß gar nicht, mag ich das Boot im Wasser lieber? Und schiesst einfach 30 Meter in die Luft, so schnell, dass selbst die Fluginstinkte der Ente nicht klarkommen und sie einfach runterfällt, einfach auf dem Boden. Ja, aber das finde ich schon spannend, weil was für ein entenfeindlicher Ort, sondern Freizeitparks. Aber ich glaube, Enten haben auch keinen guten Bezug zu Wasser, weil manchmal ist es gefroren, hart, manchmal schießt es, manchmal kommt es von oben, die checken das ja nicht, denken sich, was ist das für ein... Also ein Element, zu dem wir uns hingezogen fühlen magisch, ist auch irgendwie ein bisschen das wechselseitigste. Kein Vertrauen einfach, kein Vertrauen. Es ist mal eins. Funktioniert nicht. Wohingegen Vögel und Luft, easy, passiert nichts. Manchmal ist Wind, manchmal ist Wind, manchmal ist Regen, gut, Windhose, Zyklonen. Aber Enten müssen sich manchmal denken, manchmal kommt Wasser von oben, aus dem weiten Nirvana kommt von oben Wasser, manchmal ist es hart, da ist es nicht mehr flüssig, manchmal ist es zu kalt, manchmal ist es zu warm, manchmal schmeißt es mich ins All. Ich liebe Wasser, aber ich hasse es auch. Manchmal schmeckt es nach Zitrone, manchmal nicht. Also was denn jetzt? Manchmal ist es veralt, manchmal sind da Fische drin, manchmal nicht. Manchmal nach Chlor, manchmal nicht. Was ist hier los?
Was ist ein Element, was ich liebe?
Was ist es?
Ich will mal so eine Poetry-Slammende Ente erleben,
die über ihre Liebe-Hass-Beziehungen zu Wasser spricht.
Ey, das ist gar kein schlechtes Format.
Poetry-Slam für Tiere.
So, dann jeder ist ein Tier und muss dann aus der Perspektive des Tieres.
Hatten wir, glaube ich, auch mal, bei guter Arbeit, glaube ich,
hatten wir Tier-Stand-Up.
Ja, wollten wir mal machen. Stand-Up-Schnecke, glaube ich, auch mal, bei guter Arbeit, glaube ich, hatten wir Tier-Stand-Up. Ja, wollten wir mal machen.
Stand-Up-Schnecke, glaube ich,
wollten wir machen oder sowas.
Ja, wir wollten verschiedenen Tieren Stand-Up
aus ihrer Sicht geben, was eigentlich nach wie vor
eine gute Idee ist, finde ich, weil
ja, es gibt
eine Art, eine Perspektive,
nämlich die des Menschen
auf der Stand-Up-Bühne und das wäre natürlich schon spannend.
Dass die Schnecke dann so, kennt ihr das, wenn da vor euch eine andere Schnecke ist und ihr euch denkt, Perspektive, nämlich die des Menschen auf der Senderbühne. Und das wird natürlich schon spannend aus der Geschichte.
Kennt ihr das, wenn da vor euch eine andere Schnecke ist und ihr euch denkt, Mensch, mach voran, du!
Und ihr immer denkst, soll ich jetzt überholen oder nicht?
Und dann denkst du, okay, komm, dann überhole ich jetzt.
Und merkst dann auf halber Strecke, ja. Drei Wochen später bin ich direkt neben ihm und dann gibt er Gas und du denkst dir, was soll das denn jetzt?
Ja.
Und die Schnecken so ganz langsam. Mit den Augen so gegeneinander. Ja, die Augen gegeneinander. Viele kommen erst während des Konzerts an. Aber so eine Schleimspur ist schon ungünstig, oder? Sind Schnecken schneller, die hinter anderen Schnecken? So, gibt's einen Windschatten?
Nee, nee.
Gibt's einen Schleimschatten?
Schleimschatten meine ich.
Ja, genau, auf dem Schleim des anderen.
Also kann man dann die Schleimproduktion kurzzeitig pausieren?
Ah, Schleimsparen.
Und die Schleim des anderen nutzen?
Schleimsparen.
Oder nicht? Oder ist es dann so saurutschig, die Schnecke dann so
Wow, wow, wow, einfach so völlig ausser Kontrolle.
Das Gute ist, das dreht sich so wie so ein Formel-1-Wagen so Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah schnickeln und so, wow, wow, wow, einfach so völlig außer Kontrolle. Das Gute ist, dass... Es dre Drive to Survive ist eine Formel-1-Doku auf Netflix, supergut und ich denke, diese Doku ist auch echt super gemacht und man lernt auch die Leute immer mehr kennen, Staffel für Staffel, weil es ist ja immer das Gleiche und das ist echt toll und ich wünsche mir so eine Doku für jede Sportart der Welt, weil ich habe keine Ahnung von Formel 1, interessiert mich eigentlich auch nicht, aber durch diese Doku, durch dieses Drama kommt man irgendwie total rein und ich will das für Cricket, ich will das für Snooker, ich will das für Polo, ich will das für Wasserball, ich will das für Schach, ich will das für alles, für jede Sportart der Welt, weil ich glaube, jede Sportart ist cool, wenn man mal drin ist, wenn man mal reinkommt in die Sache und es ist großartig, es ist immer ein seltsames Leben. Leistungssport ist immer ein bisschen weird. Ja. Weil du natürlich dein ganzes Leben auf ein Spiel fokussierst, ist natürlich immer wahnsinnig seltsam. Und da liegt natürlich auch so eine Faszination drin, weil da so eine künstliche Fallhöhe irgendwie entstanden ist. Ja, das check ich auch immer noch nicht bei Formel 1, wann die denn wirklich üben. Also weil, ich meine, die fahren ja auf den Strecken, da ist dann halt eine Strecke irgendwie in Abu Dhabi. Und da kannst du ja nicht einfach dann hin und sagen, ja, ich drehe jetzt immer ein paar Runden, wenn du auf der anderen Seite der Welt bist. Im Sim. So, das heißt, du hast dann irgendwelche Sims, weil das Tolle ist, wenn du keine Ahnung von Formel 1 ist, wie ich, und du schaust diese Serie, dann alles, was du siehst am Training, ist, dass die so Tennisbälle hoch und runter werfen. Und Reaktionstest. So einen Tennisball gegen die Wand und den dann fangen. Und ich denke mir so, das ist es? Vielleicht bin ich der beste Formel-1-Fahrer. Oder dann hat der Trainer so Tennisbälle links und rechts in der Hand und lässt einen fallen und dann muss man ihn ganz schnell packen. So Reaktionsspiele. Und man denkt sich, setzt euch doch mal ins Auto rein, also versucht doch, hilft es nicht mehr. Aber ich habe keine Ahnung, wie es läuft, aber es ist toll. Spiel Playstation, ich stelle euch eine Playstation auf. Ja, das denke ich mir auch, sind die dann in Playstation auch die Besten der Welt? Nee. Oder nicht, da gibt es doch so Hardcore-Freaks, die dann den ganzen Tag Playstation spielen. Da kann ich nur den Twitch-Channel von Lando Norris ans Herz legen, der sehr viel twitcht und da auch immer wieder verliert, aber auch mit seinem Team, der ist aber auch aus Profisbestand, das 24-Stunden-Rennen gewonnen hat in so einem Race-Sim. Der spielt dann auch sehr gut, aber um den Fall zu beantworten, die haben Simulatoren, die werden dann nicht gezeigt, weil das so ein bisschen auch immer so die Herzstücke der Formel-1-Teams sind, was die für Simulatoren haben und benutzen und wie die funktionieren. Und die haben richtig, richtig, richtig gute realitätsnahe Simulatoren, die genau deren Sitz nachgestellt ist und deren Position im Auto. Und die darf man aber nicht selber spielen. Also die kann man nicht auf der Playstation rausbringen. Ich glaube, es gibt alte Simulatoren, die inzwischen komplett überholt sind. Die kannst du, da kannst du ja mal einen Tag, können wir uns nochmal mieten. Geil. Und dann fahren wir mal schön Formel 1 in einem Simulator. Ja, meine These ist ja immer, Sportdokus sind dann interessant, wenn es eine Kommunikation gibt. Also wenn Leute während dem Spiel miteinander reden können. Das ist zum Beispiel auch bei Dota cool, weil Dota spielt zu fünf gegen fünf und die Teams reden die ganze Zeit miteinander. Aber wird das bei der Übertragung auch übertragen? Nein, bei der Übertragung nicht. Das ist ja bei Formel 1 das Beste. Genau, und vor allem in der Doku kannst du dann sagen, weil es ist immer so, ja, wie fühlen die sich, woran denken die und die sprechen ja die ganze Zeit und das ist halt super cool. Aber die beschweren sich eigentlich nur. Weil du den Kopf gucken kannst. Wohin ist es, wenn du eine Doku über Tennis machst, der Tennisspieler wärmt ein Spiel, ich meine, der sagt ja nichts. Der sagt ab und zu, sorry, mir ist der Schläger runtergefallen. Oder, verdammt, aber es gibt keine Kommunikation. Deswegen glaube ich, ist ein Teamsport da interessanter für Dokus, weil du eine Kommunikation hast, auf die du zugreifen kannst. Also kommt mal an. Hat sich mal ein Tennisspieler versprochen beim Fluchen? Das finde ich lustig. Was passiert mir auch ständigste. Weil was passiert mir ja auch ständig, wenn man dann beim Autofahren oder so, oder man regt sich mal irgendwie zu Hause alleine auf über etwas, und dann verspricht man sich aber währenddessen oder so, oder man ist dann doch nicht so cool, wie man sich eigentlich gerade laut beschweren wollte. Und das denk ich mir, wenn du dann in so einem Wimbledon-Arena bist und sagst dann so, verdammte Hacke, aber verspricht sich dann dabei oder sagst, was total peinlich ist oder so. Ja, es gibt einen ganz ganz tollen Clip, den man bestimmt findet, weil es ist ja verboten, dass du als Tennisspieler deinen Schläger kaputt machst, Racket Abuse, und dann gibt es so ein Video, wo die halt mit voller Wucht ihren Schläger auf den Boden hauen aus Wut und dann kriegen die diese Strafe und dann sagen die, I just dropped it, I just dropped it, it slipped out of my hand. Immer dazwischen geschnitten dann die Wiederholung, wie er den wütend auf dem... Fünfmal einfach gegen die Wand donnert oder auch jemand wirft so eine Wasserflasche gegen die Wand. I was trying to drink and it slipped out of my hand. It slipped out of my hand, it slipped out of my hand. So lustig. Ja. Und die Schiedsrichter auch so... We got this on camera. Also he is twenty thousand people watching us. Schauen Millionenauen Millionen Menschen zu. Grossartig. Wie Leute einfach dieses dumme, kindliche, instinkthafte Lügen. Das ist so tief drin, einfach wenn du erwischt wirst. Nee, war ich nicht. Nee, ist mir nur aus der Hine gefallen. Jeder hat es gesehen. Wir können es uns in Zeitlupe noch mal angucken. Es ist jetzt auch große Diskussionen über den Dresscode bei Wimbledon, weil da kam ja jemand mit seinen Air Jordans, mit seinen roten Air Jordans auf den Platz gelaufen und man soll bei Wimbledon nur Weiss tragen, weisse Schuhe, weisse Hosen, weisses Shirt, weisses Haarband, weisse. Der wollte sich verstecken auf dem roten Platz, dass man die Füsse nicht sieht. bei Wimbledon, aber ja, ich wollte nur kurz, wenn ich die Wahl habe hier im Podcast zwischen Gag und ich ich weiß mal was, dann natürlich nehme ich das, ich weiß mal einmal was. Ich verstehe es. Und genau, da gab es Ärger ein bisschen auf der Pressekonferenz und dann war ein so ein pedantischer Journalist, er wollte immer wissen, also gelten die Regeln für Sie nicht oder warum haben Sie das so noch? Und er hat gesagt, da kommst du auch nicht raus, weil aber auch er hat das in Kindlichen, ihn ziemlich ablegen können zu sagen, nö, ich habe es einfach getragen, weil ich das jetzt wollte. Dann war es immer so ein, nee, die Regeln gelten für jeden, ich respektiere die ja auch, ich wollte an dem Tag einfach nur meine Air Johnson ziehen. Es ist immer so ein Baby-Kleinkind, was nicht die Wahrheit sagt, aber offensichtlich die Diskussion schon lange verloren hat, auf verlorenen Posten kämpft. Wir waren auch letzte Woche auf verlorenen Posten, wir haben nämlich richtig Ärger bekommen von der Community, kann man glaube ich so sagen, denn wir haben gesagt, oh wie toll es ist, erwachsen zu sein, wir können ja machen, was wir wollen. Haben wir eine Meldung im Reddit bekommen, wo jemand geschrieben hat, nee, ich bin ein Kind, ich kann nicht machen. Ah, okay. Also es hören anscheinend auch Kinder zu, was uns natürlich sehr freut, aber dann müssen wir natürlich vieles zurücknehmen, was wir letzte Woche gesagt haben, weil wir so mit stolzgeschwellter Brust rumgelaufen sind und gesagt haben, wir können machen, was wir wollen, wir können Torten essen, so viel wir wollen, denn dieses eine Kind sitzt zu Hause und sagt, ja, aber ich nicht, meine Mutter erlaubt mir das nicht. Hat das spezifiziert das Kind, wie alt es ist? Nein. Nein.
Weil ich habe noch nie ein Kind gesehen, was von sich aus gesagt hat, ich bin ein Kind.
Es ist wie eine Taube, die sagt, ich bin eine Taube.
Du hast nicht viel mit Kindern zu tun.
Du hast erschreckend wenig mit Kindern zu tun.
Warum hast du eigentlich so wenig mit Kindern zu tun? Warum hast du so viel mit Kindern zu tun? Das ist die wichtigere Frage.
Das ist die Nachricht.
Die Nachricht ist, ich bin nicht erwachsen, es gibt auch Kinder, die hören, habt ihr in Honig gesagt, smiley. Das sind eine Menge wütende Emojis auf jeden Fall. Aber interessant. Ja, liebe Grüße auf jeden Fall an der Stelle. Wir versuchen ab jetzt das Programm kindgerechter zu machen. Also wir lieben Buntstifte und diese Slinkies, also diese weichen Federn und diese Holzfigur, wo man unten an der Schnur zieht und dann streckt er so die Beine aus. Das ist auch cool. Äh, diese Achtzzen von Spieltippen. Aber was ich mich gerade frage, ich will noch kein Kind jemals hören und sagen, ich bin ein Kind. Es gibt, weil Kinder wollen doch immer erwachsen sein und sagen doch immer und freuen sich doch immer, wenn man sagt, da bist du ein grosser Mann, ne? Ja, es sei denn, es geht um Verantwortung, es sei denn, es geht darum, wer hat jetzt den Teller runtergeschmissen, ja, ich bin ja noch ein Kind. Ich bin ja noch ein Kind. Meine Hände sind so klein. Meine Hände sind so klein, ich so klein, ich bin so schwach, habe ich alles immer gehört. Ich bin so schwach. Ich habe ja Zivildienst mit Kindern gemacht und da hörst du das den ganzen Tag. Ich bin ja noch ein Kind, das kann ich nicht. Die stellen sich immer noch dümmer, als sie eigentlich sind und sagen, ich bin ja nur ein Kind. So, und jetzt nochmal, wir räumen die letzten Folgen auf. Holt den Besen raus, wir räumen die Folgen auf. Und zwar, ja, es gab Stephans Evolutionsecke mal wieder. Und da haben wir einen ganz tollen Beitrag bekommen. Warum sind nur wir so klug? Warum werden nicht alle Spezies immer intelligenter? Weil Intelligenz gleich angepasst sein. Und Stefan passt sich an. Das macht ihn zu einem hochentwickelten Organismus, denn Stefan kann sich anpassen an seine Umgebung und dazu gehört eben auch Kritik aus dem Forum, aus dem Reddit. Ich finde es ganz toll, da kam eine Nachricht von BK-2CB, ich weiß nicht, ob man solche Namen dann vorlesen sollte, da habe ich keine Erfahrung. Florentin guckt mich lachend an, anscheinend nicht. Also, mein Standpunkt zu Stefans Fragethema, warum nicht einfach alle Spezies immer mehr intelligenter werden, habe ich so gesprochen, werden und eine allgemeine Intelligenz entwickeln, so wie es beim Spezies Mensch ist. Das hier hat man angesprochen, ja, das haben wir alles schon angekündigt. Er fragt zum Beispiel, warum Kolibris zu ihrem langen Schnabel nicht einfach auch noch intelligenter werden, das wäre evolutionär vorteilhaft. Warum passiert das also nicht? Und jetzt hat er schon vorweggenommen, oder sie, mehr Intelligenz ist nicht immer gleich gut.
Erstens, mehr Gehirn, beziehungsweise mehr Intelligent, kostet mehr Energie und es ist am vorteilhaftesten, nicht mehr Energie zu verbrauchen als nötig.
Das ist eigentlich das wichtigste Prinzip der Evolution. Es setzen sich nicht die Individuen einer Spezies durch, die stärker, die schlauer oder die schneller sind als ihre Artgenossen,
es setzen sich die durch, pflanzen sich am meisten fort, die am besten angepasst sind. Ich glaube, Stefan Weiss ist auch. Ja, genau. Ja, das war ja auch mein Punkt. Ich dachte halt, dass Angepasstsein und Intelligenz ja auch einhergehen. Aber man kann doch nicht sagen, nur weil es ein kleineres Gehirn hat, ist es nicht so schlau, oder? Das kannst du doch nicht machen. Zweitens, aufgrund der Evolution entwickeln sich Spezies immer entsprechend ihrer Umwelt, ihres Lebensraumes. Lebens passen sich also an ihre ökologische Nische an. In wie vielen Nischen braucht man gar keine so hohe Intelligenz wie die Menschen? Das kann ich mir auch vorstellen. Das klingt so ein bisschen herablassen, das klingt so ein bisschen Humansplaining. Ihr müsst gar nicht so intelligent sein, ihr braucht das ja gar nicht. Warum wollt ihr denn zum Mond fliegen, warum wollt ihr denn ein Dach über den Kopf, warum wollt ihr eine Heizdecke, ihr dummen Ende. Mir gefällt Humansplaining sehr gut.
Eine anthropozentristische
Lebensweise.
Ihr müsst doch gar nicht, seid doch froh, dass ihr nicht
so ein schweres Gehirn habt.
Sie schreibt dann auch,
das Gehirn bei Kolibris dürfte nicht ein Gramm schwerer
sein, sonst könnte nicht mehr fliegen. Okay,
erklär mir ein Wal.
Ein Wal ist riesig, ein Wal kann locker
noch eine Tonne Gehirn obendrauf ballern. Vor allem ein Walgehirn ist doch grösser als menschliches Gehirn, oder? Also diese Größe des Gehirns Argument ist doch Quatsch. Von dem Stegosaurus, das Gehirn ist so gross wie eine Walnuss. Die sind so dumm, ey. Und dann habe ich den Brachiosaurus gesehen im Naturhistorischen Museum in Berlin. Und der ist 18 Meter hoch und hat auch ein Gehirn, was so gross ist wie so ein Apfel. Also, ich weiß nicht. So, guck mal. Punkt drei ist wirklich. Ein Walgehirn wiegt acht Kilo. Das ist ja wohl mehr als ein menschliches Gehirn. Und trotzdem sind Wale dumm wie Brot und können nichts.
Die können nichts.
Die können nicht mal das leichteste Sudoku lösen,
nicht mal dieses wirklich Einsteiger-Sudoku,
wo am Anfang noch die Regeln erklärt werden,
wo du irgendwie noch pro Reihe vielleicht zwei Zahlen reinschreiben musst.
Nicht mal das kriegen die hin.
Die kriegen es nicht hin.
Die sagen, fuck, man, ich krieg's nicht hin, ich schaff's nicht. Was sagen die, ich krieg's nicht hin, fuck, ich krieg's nicht hin? Ja, man. Oh man, ey, die sieben, ja, grad die sieben, ey, das kann ich nicht. Hast du den Schläger gerade hingeworfen? Hast du gerade den Schläger hingeworfen? Nein, nein, der ist mir aus der Flosse gerutscht. Ist das so aus, als du den Schläger hingeworfen? Nein, der ist mir aus, ich hab doch nur die Flossen, ich habe doch nur diese riesigen Flossen. Also das ist Quatsch, abgelehnt, abgelehnt, ich lehne es ab. Okay, Punkt vier, allgemeine Intelligenz und der Mensch sind gar nicht so, jetzt aufzuschreien, sind nicht so toll, weil teilweise, wie es teilweise getan hat, Stefan selbst hat den Podcast auch schon mal die bei Menschen hat die Evolution Aufgehör-These vertreten. Das stimmt natürlich nicht.
Da die Evolution laut Theorie ein Prozess ist,
der sich aus den Naturgesetzen ergeben,
die dem Universum inhärent sind und niemals aufhören können oder werden.
Dem Universum inhärent?
Das sollte man viel häufiger sagen.
Weil es ist so inhaltsleer, dem Universum inhärent.
Es gibt nichts Inhaltsleeres,
das ist dem Universum inhärent.
Was ist dem Universum nicht inhärent?
Ja, genau.
Was ist dem Universum exherent?
Das ist mal meine Frage.
Das Ding ist halt, dass Evolution langsam geht
Vielen Dank. Was ist dem Universum nicht inherent? Was ist dem Universum exherent? Das ist mal meine Frage. Das Ding ist halt, dass Evolution langsam geht und besonders bei Spezies mit Verhältnissen, wie sich langsam Fortpflanzungszyklus wie dem Mensch merkbare Veränderungen ewig dauern. Ja, bei dir vielleicht. Weil du dich so häufig fortpflanzt. Ich schweige und geniesse. Man muss schon sagen, ich bin ja schon gross. Größer als Menschen zum Beispiel, wenn ich diese kleinen Ritterrüstungen sehe, wo ich mir denke, dann ist er irgendwie so ein krasser Krieger aus dem 15. Jahrhundert und dann sieht man so die Rüstung und das ist ein ganz kleiner Mann gewesen. Ich denke mir, zieh die Rüstung an, besorg dir dein langen Schwert und dann lauf auf mich zu, ich baller dich weg, ich kann ihn mit meinen langen Beinchen so weghalten. Ich kann ja mein Bein hochhalten. Ja, so einfach die Hand an die Stirn. Und der kommt nicht ran mit seiner Muskete, mit seiner Arkebuse. Nee, mit seiner Arkebuse. Vor allem, Stefan Tietze ist ja das beste Beispiel für Evolution, denn du bist immun gegen Aids. Und das lässt du einen auch nicht vergessen. Immer wenn man mit dir unterwegs ist, jede Spritze auf dem Boden, leckst du ab und überall an jedem, jeder Klobrennel leckst du ab, weil der sagt, ich bin immun gegen Aids, ich kann es nicht kriegen und ihr vielleicht, aber unwahrscheinlich zum Glück, es ist nicht mehr so verbreitet. Und es ist auch nicht mehr schlimm und es ist auch einfach heilbar. Aber ich krieg's nicht, niemals. Nee, heilbar ist nicht, ich glaube, es ist gut behandelt. Aber wenn man unterwegs ist abends und man geht mit mir mal los und so und dann bin ich kurz mal weg an der Bar und so und dann hört man, wenn man leise ist,
hört man im Hintergrund dann so,
das muss man schauen soll. Soll ich mich wirklich aus der gleichen
Flasche trinken? Also ich bin ja
Eizimon, also mir macht es mir hinzahmen.
Mein Gott.
Ja, aber irgendwann, wie gesagt,
ich versuche ja immer noch, dich zu motivieren,
dich vorzupflanzen. Muss ja auch jetzt nicht, sag ich mal, im klassischen Sinne sein. Also bei dir ist ja auch eine Spende möglich oder irgendwas damit. Ja, Gänzglas. Weil wir können, allein durch dich können wir die Menschheit verbessern. Es ist ja ein klarer Vorteil, immun gegen Aids zu sein. Es ist eine Abwägungsfrage. Du hast jetzt nicht nur Vorteile, aber wie gesagt, man müsste jemand anderen finden,
der dich da gut ergänzt.
Und dann kannst du das machen.
Ach ja, es gibt das Gegenteil an der Trichterbrust,
die Keilbrust, die geht nach vorne.
Und wenn man Glück hat, kommt die Mitte raus.
Das wäre so gut, wenn du jemanden mit Keilbrust findet,
und dann könnt ihr euch perfekt umarmen.
Wie so zwei Puzzlestück. Ying und Yang. So richtig perfekt. Genau wie diese eine Doku, die ich gesehen habe von diesem Arzt, der so Pärchen geholfen hat, die Kinder kriegen wollten. Und der dann einfach, normalerweise gibt es ja so eine Spermaspendenbasis, Samenspendenbasis, wo dann die Leute sich das auch aussuchen können oder so. Und der hat gesagt,, mach mal mal meins lieber, nee, mach mal immer meins, also immer meinen Samen, also meinen eigenen.
und er hatte einfach immer und er hatte einfach hunderte
tausende Nachfahren, weil
er einfach immer seinen eigenen Samen verwendet
hat. Selbst bei Leuten, also
ein Pärchen, die ihr eigenes
also Mann und Frau und der hat
seinen eigenen Samen mitgebracht, der nur eingepflanzt
werden sollte, hat er gesagt, nee, komm, schmeiß das weg. Nee, hat er das dann öffentlich gemacht oder hat er das im Geheimen ausgetaucht? Geheim natürlich. Okay. Wenn ein Pärchen zum Arzt geht und sagt, wir wollen ein Kind kriegen und der schmeißt das weg und sagt, nee, nee, komm, mach mal lieber meins. Und irgendwann kam das raus, weil dann auch so Erbkrankheiten Thema war und dann halt irgendwann die halbe Stadt einfach aus Kindern von ihm bestanden. Das gibt es ja nicht. Wo dann auch irgendwann Inzest einfach ein Thema ist, weil die ja nicht wissen, dass sie verwandt sind. Aber einfach, ich mag diesen grössenwahnsinnigen Ansatz des, nee, ich werde einfach mal Tausende Nachfahren haben. Nee, ich, nee, nee, ich, meine, nee, meine Gene, nee, schon ich. Das ist ja Wahnsinn. Nee, nicht der Typ, nicht der Typ, nee, ich. Ich. Mehr von mir. Von mir. Also ich, dass es halt mehr von mir gibt. Wieso nicht mehr von mir? Und das ist ja, glaube ich, schon, also wenn wir jetzt über Evolution reden, das ist ja auch eine evolutionäre Strategie. Vielleicht ist dieser Arzt ja auch next level, der einfach sagt, das ist ja die bestmögliche, also nach Genghis Khan ist ja das die bestmögliche Fortpflanzungsstrategie der Welt, werde Arzt für Fortpflanzungsmedizin und baller einfach überall deine eigenen Samen rein. Also das ist evolutionär gesehen, wo wir es gerade mal ganz, also moralisch natürlich grau, sagen wir mal. Grauzone. Klassische Grauzone. Ich meine, es ist auch schwer, da eine Straftat zu finden. Was genau ist das jetzt?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, es ist eine ganz klare Straftat. Betrug? Keine Ahnung, er hat ja keinen finanziellen Vorteil davon. Der Kaufvertrag ist ja abgeschlossen worden. Das stimmt. Aber es ist ja eine evolutionare Fortpflanzungsstrategie, die extrem erfolgreich war. Wie schlimm. Ja, wie schlimm. Was ich mich... Ja, also stell dir mal vor, dann ...
Als Vater freust du dich dann, dass ein Kind, wir kommen jetzt endlich, das ist ja auch immer so wahnsinnige Wunschkinder, wenn halt man dann schon da ist, dass man dann irgendwann, ja, so In-Vitro-Fertilisation oder so was oder so Reagenzglas-Kinder, das macht man ja nicht als erstes, sondern da ist ja schon davor wahrscheinlich ein Kind versucht worden. Ich glaube, das wurde dann schon der Frau eingepflanzt. Ja, genau. So was, hundertprozentig sicher, es gab unterschiedliche Methoden. Und dann sieht es immer mehr aus wie der Arzt. So ein kleines Stethoskop umhalt. Und die so fragen, hä, wir haben gar keinen Ärzten in unserer Familie. Ne, unterschreibt doch noch mal hier. Unterschreibt doch mal hier den Namen, Martin. Und einfach nur einen Strich. Moment mal. Der Vater bricht in Tränen aus. Aber liebst du dann als Vater noch dein Kind. Mutter, Mutter, ich habe mir meinen Thermoporax gebrochen. Oh fuck, Moment mal. Und dann zum Arzt gehen und sagen, ich glaube, sie haben uns betrogen. Und das Kind so, ja, ich habe hier so Dermaziten im Hals irgendwo. Also hier hinten habe ich so einen ganz ermatologischen Konfekt eigentlich. Ich habe eine Frage an dich. Die ist ein bisschen ... Zotig? Schlüpfrig? Nein, nicht schlüpfrig, aber die ist ... I like it! Das ist eine edgy Frage. Gib es mir. Wie viel Prozent, also ab und zu legen sich Katzen auf Babys, weil die Babys sind warm und Katzen wollen es warm haben und dann bringen die Katzen so Babys. Ach so, aber auf Menschenbabys, nicht auf Katzenbabys. Katzen legen sich auf Menschenbabys und töten Kinder. Wie viel Prozent der Besitzer behalten danach die Katze? Guter Punkt, ja, guter Punkt. Oder wie viel Prozent der Besitzer holen sich eine Katze, nachdem sie ein Kind bekommen haben, weil sie denken, ja das nervt schon ein bisschen. Also ich will nichts, ich will nichts, ich will nichts, um Gottes willen, der Herr spricht! Der Herr. Oh nein, welcher Kreis der Hölle wird es sein? Ich hoffe, man hört, dass die Glocken sind in dem Moment angegangen, in dem ich in den Raum gestellt habe, dass Leute versuchen Kinder umbringen versuchen. Ja, okay. Nein, wir sind ja auch gegen Abtreibung. Jesus, sorry, sorry, Lord. Ist ja gut, mein Herr. Sag mal ehrlich, weil, ich meine, man hat eine Katze, die man liebt. Man hat ein Kind, was man liebt. Katze tut Kind, und dann willst du beides, was du vorher geliebt hast, verlieren? Gut, aber ich komme darauf an, zeigt die Katze Reue oder nicht? Nee, es ist eine Katzenkatze, es ist eine Katze, die jetzt wenig menschliche Emotionen zeigen kann. Also gar kein Schuldbewusstsein, gar nichts. Wahrscheinlich schon, aber was heißt, wie zeigt denn die Katze Schuldbewusstsein? Der Herr straft mich, der Herr schickt mir einen furchtbaren Husten. Ja, es ist wirklich eine gute Frage. Ist eine gute Frage. Wer behält zumindest die Katze? Weil die macht dir nicht das Kind böswillig umgebracht, sondern sich draufgelegt, wollte schmusen und es ist schön warm. Die wollte das Baby nicht umbringen. Wie viele Eltern behalten dann zumindest noch die Katze? Weil sonst verlierst du ja beides. Du verlierst ja... Ach Gott, was für ein schreckliches Gespräch. Du hast dein Kind verloren und sitzt am Tisch und sagst ... Jetzt müssen wir schon die Katze tottreten, oder? Also ... ja, okay, okay, okay, Frage. Wie viel Prozent lässt du einschläfern? Stell dir vor, du kriegst ein neues Kind und die gleiche Katze. Oh Mann, spät ist es da und sagst du ... weisst du was? Nee, aber dann musst du die Katze wiederbehalten. Nein, nein, nein, nein, dann gab es ja schon den Präzedenzfall. Dann musst du die Katze wiederbehalten. Das stimmt. Ich frage mich nur... Ja, du kannst da nicht das zweite Verbrechen anders behandeln als das erste, das stimmt schon. Nuller pöne sie ne Legge, sage ich da immer. Das sagen wir alle. Ich würde behaupten, man gibt die Katze eher ab, als dass man sie behält. Und ich würde behaupten... Ja, aber stell dir vor, du gibst es dann an so ein Pärchen. Ja, suchen eine Katze, wir suchen, oh toll, eine Katze und wir wollten jetzt auch keine ganz kleine Katze. Und dann ruft man nach so einem Jahr an, wie es gelaufen ist und sie sagt, das hat unser Kind, und man sagt so, was, oh nein, die Mara, oder wie ist das passiert, wie hat sie sich draufgelegt, wie ist das passiert? Ich hatte ... Moment mal. Ja, draufgelegt.
Ach so, weil das machen Katzen ja.
Aber es ist so ...
Ich frage wirklich, glaubst du, die meisten lassen sie einschläfern?
Kann man zum Tierarzt gehen und sagen, meine Katze hat mein Kind umhört?
Wisst ihr was, meine Katze ist ein Arschloch.
Geben Sie da einfach hier das Taubermittel.
Nee, das macht man ja auch nicht.
Jesus, der Herr ist echt erbost über unser Thema. Wir nehmen übrigens um 36 Uhr auf, von daher ist das jetzt natürlich ein bisschen nervig gerade. Aber ja, es ist schon eine gute Frage. Kann man strafrechtlich gegen eine Katze vorgehen? Nein. Und die Todesstrafe fordern und sagen, Tierarzt ... Ist echt keine schlechte Frage. Kann man einfach so zum Tierarzt gehen und sagen, bring meine Katze um. Killer.
Weil, macht der das oder denkt der sich, ja gut, wenn ich es nicht mache, dann werfen die den jetzt rein oder fahren mit dem Rasenmäher drüber oder was. Ich weiß es nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Oh Gott. Ich weiß es nicht, ob man das gerade, also Hunde werden ja eingeschläfert, wenn die ein Kind getötet haben. Es ist so ein Ding, so, nee, nee, Menschen sind noch wichtiger, und dann werden die auf dem Dorfplatz erhängt, um der Welt zu zeigen, nee, Kinder sind noch wichtiger. Ich weiß es nicht, ich kenne mich da nicht aus mit den Gesetzesmitgliedern. Ich frage mich nur, prozentual, vielleicht machen wir das als neue Rubrik, edgy Fragen am Ende. Prozentual! Prozentual, wie viele bringen die Katze, lassen sie umbringen, wie viel einschläfern, wie viel Prozent geben sie einfach nur ab und wie viel Prozent behalten sie? Und das finde ich am spannendsten. Wie viel Prozent behalten ihre Kindstöten? Ich glaube, die behalten schon viel, oder? Und dann schmusen die mit der dann am Tag. Ab wann? Nach zwei Wochen, nach drei? Ab wann? Ja, muss schon eine Woche Pause machen. Wann kriegt die wieder so ein Leckerli, so ein Treat? Ja, ja, ja, ja. Wann wird die wieder gekraut? Nimmt man der den Kratzbaum weg? Das Schafe! Es ist nicht leicht, es ist wirklich nicht leicht. Weil Familien lieben ja auch ihre Katzen. Ja, ja, und das ist ja dann alles, was du noch hast, im Zweifelsfall. Also wenn du die auch noch tot trittst, dann fängst du ja wieder komplett bei null an. Dann bist du bei null, dann verlierst du hundert Prozent. Wenn das Kind nur weg ist, gut, das ist eins, eins, zwei, drei, fünf, sieben. Ja, sag mal 80, ja gut, 70. Ja, ist schwierig, ist wirklich schwierig. Ich finde das eine spannende Frage. Vielleicht haben wir da eine Antwort, vielleicht gibt es da die Antwort im Internet auch zu finden. Hat jemand von euch schon mal ähnliche Erfahrungen? Mörderkatze. Ja, Mörderkatze war. Furchtbar. Naja, sorry, dass wir euch jetzt mit diesem merkwürdigen Thema die Woche entlassen. Aber vielleicht können wir uns alle diese Frage mal stellen, was wir machen würden. Ich würde sie abgeben. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das ganz ... Ich weiß, es passiert auch nicht so häufig. Es passiert auch nicht so häufig, glaube ich. Ach. Es ist auch eine Fortpflanzungsstrategie. Es ist einfach ... Die Katzen sind ja auch eifersüchtig. Wenn dann ein anderes Baby ist und es kriegt alle Aufmerksamkeit. Ich glaube, die wissen das schon, was sie macht. Die wissen schon, was sie macht. Oh Gott, ey. Tira, ich schwank wirklich Woche für Woche, und das ist bei mir immer ewiges Hin und Her. Ich schwank immer hin und her zwischen, Tiere sind viel schlauer als ich dachte, und Tiere sind Strodum, können nichts. Und es gibt jetzt diese Doku über die Geheimfähigkeiten unserer Haustiere und so. Und da geht es darum, was Tiere für besonderes ... So geheim können sie da nicht sein. Bis jetzt waren sie geheim. Netflix lüftet, lupft den Vorhang. Und dann gibt es Tiere, die verschiedene Fähigkeiten haben. Unter anderem Ratten, die Autofahren. So, die haben kleine Autos. Und wo fahren die ja hin? Kleine Rattenautos. Und da setzen die sich rein. Und dann haben die so einen Knopf zum Lenken. Haben die Helm auf? Nein, auch nicht angeschnallt. Die einfach keine Versicherung, keine Führerschein, nicht mal einen Sehtest. Blinken die für die hinteren Ratten, wenn sie die Spur wechseln wollen? Oder fahren die egoistisch scheiße? Gar nichts, auf der falschen Spurseite. Und die können trainiert werden, dass sie halt zu so einem Leckerli hinfahren.
So, und das ist einfach das Beste,
was es gibt. Wenn ihr diese Woche ... Schreiten die sich, wenn die sich auf dem
Beifahrersitzenden Ratten und sagt, nee, du hättest ja abgemusst.
Zum Leckerli hättest du ja abgemusst.
Ja, die Ausfahrt,
Entschuldigung, ich hab's zu spät gesehen.
Also, falls ihr eine schlechte Woche habt,
schaut euch zumindest das an.
Wenn das nicht hilft, dann kann ich euch nicht helfen. Schaut euch zumindest die autofahrenden Ratten an. Es ist ein Traum. Weil erst lernen die nur geradeaus zu fahren und dann denkt man sich, naja gut, die checken halt, wenn ich auf den Knopf drücke, dauert es ein bisschen und dann kriege ich ein Leckerli. Das checken die schon, aber die verstehen nicht, dass sie fahren. und dann fangen die an zu lenken und du denkst dir, oh, das ist das Beste, was ich je gesehen habe. Das ist einfach das Beste, was ich je gesehen habe. Vielleicht ist das sogar klüger als selbstfahrende Autos. Es gibt ja grosse moralische Debatten über selbststeuernde Autos, wer ist verantwortlich, wenn jemand überfahren wird und so weiter und so weiter. Vielleicht sollte man einfach sagen, nee, lass uns lieber schlaue Ratten die Autos fahren, die Autos fahren, wir sitzen hinten drin und damit man zumindest dann irgendwie so eine Ratte in den Mülleimer werfen kann, wenn die was angestellt hat, damit du uns schuldigen hast. Jetzt mal ganz viert gefragt. Das fühlt sich besser an. Wer ist die bessere Spezies? Die Spezies, die über Jahrtausende irgendwann zu Autos kommt und die entwickelt, oder die Spezies, die sich von einer anderen Spezies Autos bauen lässt? Das stimmt. Und fahren beibringen lässt. Ja, das stimmt. Umsonst. Nee, nee, nicht mal. Sie kriegen was dafür. Hier, Christ und Leckerli dafür, dass wir dir ein Auto gebaut haben, was du jetzt fahren darfst, wir bringen es dir bei. Die Belohnung für die Raten sind Fruit Loops. Haben die auch nicht selber entwickelt. Die haben einfach eine andere Spezies für sich über Jahrhunderte die perfekte Cornflakes-Art entwickelt. Wenn man diese Testaufbau, so eine grosse Strasse mit kleinen Autos, dann nehmen sie einfach Florentin in seinem Auto, für den das Ziel Fruit Loops auch ausreicht, um sich in ein Auto zu setzen. Er hat sich in das Institut geschlichen, er kam durch die Tür, wir wissen bis heute nicht wie, so Nagespuren an der Türklinke. Und ja, er fährt auch Auto. Er hört dabei WDR 2. Deutschlandfunk. Meistens schaffen es aber die Ratten vor ihm, am Fruit Loop zu sein. Er hat noch Schwierigkeiten mit der Lenkung ein bisschen, aber er wird besser. Aber Florentin liebt Fruit Loops so sehr, dass er auch bei diesem Versuch dabei sein muss. Da sind es die amerikanischen oder die deutschen Fruit Loops. Diese Schärfe. Ja, die deutschen Fruit Loops, wo der ganze Zucker rausgenommen ist. Nee, schon die Amis. Dann nennen die nicht Fruit Loops. Sondern? Da ist im Loch mehr Geschmack als in den Fruit Loops, sag ich euch. So Leute, wir sind raus. Hab noch eine schöne Woche. Wir hören uns. Und schreibt uns mal eure Tipps, wie viele Familien, deren Katzen, Kinder behalten die Katzen. Oder denkt einfach nie wieder darüber nach. Oder denkt darüber wieder darüber nach und wir sehen uns nächste Woche schön in Hannover, falls ihr Lust habt.
So machen wir es nämlich.
Macht's gut.
Ciao, ciao.
Tschüss, macht's gut, wir heben ab.
Küsschen.
Tschüss.
It's a worse bird, bitch. Ah! Lotto Bayern, nimm dein Glück in die Hand.